hey guys all of our games have concluded
i'm here with fabiano caruana you drew
today and on on and it looks like you
had a nice advantage and a lot of great
opening preparation tell us about that
um yeah I he played this move Queen g6
which i think is a very good move uh at
least practically speaking and I had the
option to play e5 which is very sharp
were quieter whipped with not d1 and I I
mean I I didn't have much in sending
that maybe I should have gone for you
part but um I had some slight chances
and then I got very optimistic after
after the time control because I
actually thought I was winning um what
after King f7 is just the draw I think I
i thought four I made 40 minutes and I
couldn't find a single idea was this the
main line of your preparation or did you
spend a lot of time on 93 no the main
line is 93 I thought that Queen g6 is
unlikely to happen and I I really
couldn't remember what happens after you
five so it's risky for both sides and
somehow I felt like a quieter game than
that alright so one round left is a
grand gesture and the London chess
classic um what are your predictions in
the final round uh so I think Mickey and
I were the only ones with all drawers um
so if there's a decisive result that
will be pretty ironic yeah all right
well good luck tomorrow we're with
fabiano caruana and there's one land
left of the bare chest or season one